where's these injures we got finished
this marble just dropped another teaser
for Avengers endgame and while it
doesn't show much it does reveal a few
new tidbits about the movie warning
possible spoilers ahead if we do this
we'd be going in short-handed the
trailer starts out with the team
deciding to go after Thanos to avenge
their friends we see the Benatar
approaching New York then rocket and
nebula sitting on its steps both have
suffered devastating losses with nebula
losing her sister and rocket losing his
entire team including his pal Groot no
it looks like rocket is wearing his
normal outfit which is important for
what comes later in the trailer Tony and
Pepper hug we don't know how long he's
been gone or how long it took for him to
get back but this is a reunion fans have
been waiting for is this them saying
goodbye again as he goes to take on
Thanos Hawkeye has a lot more tattoos
than the last time we saw him it looks
like someone is not taking the snap well
has he lost his entire family in the
group shot rocket is the only one suited
up for action is this when the team
decides to finally take the battle to
Thanos this one's for all the fans
shipping Tony and Steve you trust me
I do next we see most of the remaining
Avengers on the benatar rocket is not
wearing the jumpsuit he had on earlier
and the team is not wearing the
spacesuits we saw in an earlier trailer
there's also no Hawkeye nebula ant-man
or Tony in this shop are they somewhere
else on the ship or taking care of a
different mission black widow has the
same short blonde hair she had an
infinity war with this trailer and
others showing longer more red hair does
this take place soon after infinity war
with other parts of the movie happening
much later it has been pointed out that
Tony's hair looks a lot grayer in some
shots could the team be going to both
space and the quantum realm
the movie is 3 hours long so there's
definitely time for both we get a
voiceover of Thanos saying you could
live with your own failure then a shot
of fan assist ship it looks like nebula
and Rhodey are both looking at the noses
giant sanctuary to ship so it seems
nebula was elsewhere on the benatar in
that group shot
Thanos beams down the way he did before
he had the space stone an infinity war
he used the space stone to teleport
around but it looks like he's back to
using his ships beam transport does this
mean he no longer has this space stone
or is it not working finally we see Tony
cap and Thor approaching Thanos on what
looks like Titan where Tony and the
others fought him in infinity war will
this be some sort of time warp was
Thanos unable to restore Titan to its
former glory what do you think did we
miss anything let us know in the
comments
you